hey you guys
movie retrospective talking about jack
the ripper
this is 2001's from hell
pretty good movie it's not bad actually
i will say
i actually really do like the look of
this movie and just the whole
aesthetic of this movie yeah now it is
based well
it's very loosely based on the alan
moore eddie campbell
graphic novel also called from hell um
and it took a lot of liberties i mean
alan moore is like famously doesn't like
adaptations of any of his stuff
um you know and and i feel like a lot of
them have been kind of unsuccessful
uh you know a watchman v for vendetta um
you know league of extraordinary
gentlemen and stuff like that so
i can see why he'd be kind of cranky
about it and i can
understand why he was cranky about this
one in particular because this one does
take a lot of liberties with it so i
will say that if
you are going to watch the movie from
hell it's probably
honestly i think you probably like it
better if you hadn't
read the graphic novel and if you didn't
know all that much about the jack the
ripper case
because this is not historically
accurate by any stretch of the
imagination no it's just a mishmash of a
bunch of ideas conspiracy theories and
it's a serial killer movie it's
fictional it's fiction yeah
it's fiction and i mean like i said it
has a great atmosphere there's a lot of
gore
it's just i mean it's really a beautiful
looking movie but like i said it's not
it's historically accurate it's actually
alan moore got the idea
for from hell from another book i think
it was by a dude named steven knight and
i think it was called
um jack the ripper the final solution
so he was the one that came up with this
whole
um sir william gull who was
in real life the physician to queen
victoria and their
contingent um being jack the ripper
and then like all the freemasons and
[ __ ] like that like covering up for them
like because there was a scandal and
there was like a baby that was
in that would have really been in
succession and blah blah
um even though there's really no real
life evidence to support that
but a lot of the people that are in this
movie and a lot of the people that he
used in the story
like alan warren the original story are
real people
he just changed them a lot to kind of
fit into the conspiracy
this is fiction yeah it's just in a
historical looking setting
uh matter of fact the setting is is good
it looks really good
um depp's english accent isn't always on
point
yeah um but it's not that bad
this is one of depths but better movies
if you ask me i mean
he's kind of hit or miss sometimes he'll
come out with something really good
sometimes it's not that good
he's always just depth the [ __ ] out
though he's depth
fine
he's always that dude he's always giant
yeah i mean that's the thing i never
fools me yeah thinking that he's
someone else no it's johnny depp doing
this thing because i think johnny depp
as a person
is just kind of so much larger than life
so i feel like when he's one of those
dudes he's like tom cruise it's like
every time you see him in a movie
it's tom cruise he never disappears into
a role
and i don't think johnny depp does
either now i don't think that that's
necessarily a bad thing it's depending
on what kind of role you're playing
what i got to say though for me tom
cruise's
best acting was probably an interview
with the vampire sorry
a lot of people that don't like yeah
movie but i think he's good when he's
playing
a villain a villain he's he's a very
good villain and he's [ __ ] kind of a
dick
like he was a dick in magnolia he was
really good in that yeah
and uh because i think that plays to his
strengths he did
kind of it's a big difference between
and rice's [ __ ] lestat and
tom cruise is the stock yeah but that
did convince me that he wasn't tom
cruise at that moment
yeah i think that's the closest thing he
ever came right
i liked that character i liked how he
did that character
depp's kind of like that you you can
tell that that's depp and he's always
going to be deaf it's
death putting on a show for you he's
always going to be dipping yeah he's
deaf in the face
this one is you but you know what i
understand it that was the
i was there during those days the
the the appeal of a move going to see a
movie that had johnny gidep in it was
that he was going to dab the [ __ ] out in
it
which is completely different than
caging the scene like cage in the [ __ ]
out
like nicholas yeah you know or you know
[ __ ]
but he doesn't i'm just telling you
that's what it is
his fans wanted that and he was a big
he's a big box office
draw yeah for a long time you know
yeah thing is is that when he live
streams he's [ __ ] like that too you
know in a way or
tries to he tries to be a more
thoughtful version of that
it's an act though he's an act i feel
like the thing about it
is that i feel like his character in
this because he plays
frederick aberline who was a real person
uh who didn't look anything like johnny
depp
yeah and and uh he was actually one of
the lead investigators on the real jack
the ripper case back in 1888
so he plays that character and i really
get the feeling
that one the character in the movie not
so much the character
in the graphic novel because he's not
really the central character of the
graphic novel jack the ripper is
um to a greater extent but in the movie
i think that he's tr they tried to make
him
sort of like sherlock holmes because he
has the whole absinthe and laudanum and
[ __ ] opium addiction which he didn't
have in the book
so i think they wanted to do a sherlock
holmes he kind of pays a drug addict
type of thing
and that kind of like helps with his uh
you know deductive powers
also the character is very similar to
his
interpretation of ichabod crane from
sleepy hollow which had come out in what
1999 i want to say so like just a year
or two before this
where he also depth the [ __ ] out now
yeah that's right
these are like very very similar
characters he's very kind of droll
and um you know so so it's kind of like
a combination of
ichabod crane from from tim burton
sleepy hollow and sherlock holmes
kind of vibe johnny depp's best movie
actually was sweeney todd i'm just
saying the musical
i really i really really like swinging
we should we should review that one
so we just uh watched it just on a whim
just a couple months ago
because we felt like it when i saw it
before i saw it in the theater okay when
it came out
you know i like musicals and then he did
a good job yeah
and he didn't dap the [ __ ] out in that
one
not really not really he he plays a
pretty good villain
yeah yeah and he's still kind of
sympathetic i guess
yeah he was a villain though yeah he was
there was just a
there's a reason for it yeah but uh this
movie i think is one of his better
movies
yeah i would i would actually agree with
that that he still
does his thing in yeah i don't i will
tell you right now i don't like this
quite as much as sleepy hollow
um but i do really actually like this
and i like it more
now okay so the thing about this like i
said it's
marginally about jack the ripper it's
marginally based on the alan moore eddie
campbell graphic novel
and it kind of has the same skeleton of
that story
in the sense that i think in jack the
ripper circles what do they call this
the royal conspiracy
like i said it comes from that book
called the final solution yeah but it's
also mixed in with masonic theory well
that was in there too
i mean all of that [ __ ] was in the
occult and stuff you know
and if any works yeah it works in the
story if anything the novel has
way more of a masonic and occult thing
to it in fact
matter of fact i think i read from hell
but it was a long time ago it came out
in the 90s
like initially it came out like one
issue at a time and then i think in 1999
they put out like a 550 page
thing of it all together i think if i
remember correctly at the end of the
novel
jack the ripper is essentially which
kind of reminds me of that star trek
episode
where they're talking about jack the
ripper being kind of almost like a demon
that like can travel through the ages so
he becomes like
later on like he becomes ian brady from
like you know the moore's murders
and he becomes like he manifests as
different murderers
like throughout history so it's almost
kind of like so that whole quote which
is at the beginning of the movie about
how like jack the ripper saying oh i
gave birth to the 20th century
um obviously jack thorpe never said that
one because they never found the dude
and two
because of the three letters that they
think were actually written by the
killer
uh he doesn't say that in any of those
so that was uh enough that was from the
novel
you know what i mean so it's weird
though because in the novel like i said
it seemed like there was a much more
of an occult thing to it and the movie
has that too but it downplays it
slightly
so i feel like some of the stuff that
they left in the movie that had kind of
an occult flavor to it they probably
should have ramped that up a little bit
like more to go with the novel because
sometimes i think some of the stuff
that's in the movie
since they're not hitting the occult
angle all that hard um
maybe it seems like if if you don't know
anything about the novel then
you might think it was kind of pointless
or why is this in here well if you don't
know anything about the real case of
jack the ripper you might think this is
historical
and i think a lot of people might did
think that this was maybe they did but
yeah this is really back in those days
you know it's really not
back in those days you know it was kind
of on the verge of internet
you know you know the internet was
around but not everybody was on it
there wasn't much to research on it it
was very incomplete
so but this is kind of like something
that you'd find off of like
internet legends about crimes yeah you
know what i mean
and some of those uh remember those fake
cases that people would make
about crimes and it sounded really
complicated you really
thought that it happened like bearing
the girl alive and yeah
what they call that it's almost kind of
like a larping type thing well it's an
arg
it's an alternate reality game right
right you're trying to make it seem as
realistic as possible
yeah back in these days there was a lot
of arg type stuff
and fact and fiction was kind of blurry
when you were young
in in those days yeah you know in this
era because it was hard to [ __ ]
confirm what was true
you know the internet didn't have a lot
of information on it
you just had to go with what so when you
what
when you watch this movie i remember
thinking that it was a lot more
historical than it really was when i
first saw it
when i first saw it i was like yeah this
is a strong theory about what really
happened
it's not though it's not it's from
fiction
yeah and like i said that's it came from
a book and you know that doesn't really
have a lot of evidence to support it
although
i will note that sir william gaul um who
spoiler alert uh ends up the surgeon he
does end up being jack the ripper in the
movie and in the novel as well
um he's played by ian holm in the movie
uh who was also bilbo baggins in the in
lord of the rings
so you know a hobbit is jack the ripper
who knew um but yeah so
uh he actually was a suspect it's so
it's not like he's just pulling this out
of his butt
it's you know but they're kind of
putting together this massive conspiracy
where there isn't any and i think kind
of the point of the novel i don't know
if alan moore really did think that the
jack the ripper murders were like this
big masonic conspiracy like to cover up
but
right like to cover up a royal scandal
or whatever but
i think he just wanted you know i don't
know a huge amount about alan moore so i
don't know he might believe
it for all i know but um you know i
think he just thought it made an
interesting story and also kind of the
point of the story too
was how it was just kind of a thing
where like the powerful can
you know [ __ ] over the underclass like
just to get what they want and they can
kind of like you know
you know have all these elaborate
stories about it and [ __ ] like that
which was a theme through a lot of his
work like v for vendetta and stuff like
that too
so it's not that unusual to see why he
would have come up with this
yeah story is those that they had so
much power they didn't have to go
through these big convoluted
um yeah because this would be pretty
convoluted
it makes a good movie though it makes a
good story but if you made if you made
enemies with that class they just killed
you they had somebody kill you
your body was just never found you
disappeared yeah i mean and i feel like
back then especially in 18 people just
like
people disappear all the time well see
that's well okay so that was one of the
things about the story if you haven't
seen from hell
like i said i will kind of like go a
little bit about it we'll talk about
where it deviates from
reality uh too so pretty much it's you
know it's 1888 obviously it's in white
chapel even though
i believe all the some of the exteriors
for this were actually shot in london
but i think most of it was shot in
prague
actually that they set dressed to look
like victorian london
so you got your prostitutes okay there's
five of them um
this is historically accurate all the
prostitutes in there
are um you know that's their names
that's the names of the women that were
killed they didn't look like that though
uh no and particularly heather graham
and i think a lot of people
uh criticized it for this because
heather graham i look i love her she was
[ __ ]
roller girl in boogie nights she's been
she's a great actress
but her um honestly her british accent
her cockney accent was
not it wasn't like keanu reeves and
francis coppola's dracula bad
yeah but it was it was a little bit
it was bothersome okay also
uh none of the prostitutes look like
that now mary kelly in real life
um did actually have a reputation of
being young
and quite pretty for the time but
what we're talking about is 1888 lower
class
britain and she's a prostitute so
beauty standards are going to be a
little mitigated that's all i'm saying
she didn't look like heather graham okay
you look she had all her teeth she was
clean she had beautiful clean hair
all right you look at the actual
photographs of those women men and they
were
hags and well they were rough you could
tell that they were
they had rough drinking like that they
drank
like fishes which they kind of do in
this movie too
but they still look okay yeah they uh
they look like derelicts
i have to say i think they were well
yeah i mean they weren't
derelicts yeah i mean all you were doing
these poor women walking around drinking
and
we're just drinking yeah they're walking
around yeah getting money for
you know blowing dudes or having sex
with dudes and allies
and then you they were just trying to
scrape up enough for a room for the
night and some booze
they were washing up and one thing that
was accurate though is that they were
washing up in the horse troughs
yeah and splashing it underneath your
legs and stuff
and they did have actually one uh scene
in this that i thought was kind of a
nice touch because this was something
that they did
back in the day they had like for
homeless people
they had what they called in the uk they
called it a dos house
and basically you would go in there to
sleep and there were
a couple there might have been like some
cots or something like that but that was
kind of like the ritzy [ __ ]
so the real cheap [ __ ] is they would you
would all sit up on like a
essentially like a bench or like a
church pew and then they would put a
rope across you so you didn't fall out
like when you slept so you basically
just like laid and i've seen like
photographs of it from the time
yeah um you paid like a penny or however
much it was that was like the cheapest
sleeping accommodation they would just
put every like a big row of people in a
bench and put a rope there so they
didn't fall out under their faces while
they were sleeping
so that's that's what we're talking
about so i do like that they had a scene
of that where all the women were
sleeping there but then then they pulled
the rope out like hey time to go girls
you know what i mean like get out of
here
so that actually was period accurate so
you have all the prostitutes and they're
all friends now
they all have um you know even though
like i said oh i will point out too that
a couple of the women
that were playing the prostitutes i
can't remember that oh my god i can't
remember their their names
but the one i think that played um annie
chapman
and i the one that played kathryn eddows
those two
actresses were in a [ __ ] ton of movies
by mike lee who i'm like a big fan of
like a british uh
director and the woman that played uh
annie chapman sadly i think this was her
last movie because she died
quite young of uh pneumonia so she died
like right after this movie came out so
i think
it was kind of creepy because she gets
murdered in this [ __ ] movie and then
like a year later she drops dead
you know what i mean so it was like
because i remember hearing about it
because i was like a big fan of hers
because
she was in like a lot of mike lee movies
and i was like holy [ __ ] she died she
was like
i said i don't even remember how old she
was maybe 40s maybe
i don't even remember she was that old
but yeah so
uh so the five of them know this woman
named anne crook
now i don't know i don't know if ann
crook was a prostitute too
or if she was i think in the original um
conspiracy theory by stephen knight i
think she was like a shop girl
so she wasn't a hooker but she was like
low class you know what i mean so the
premise of this is that ann
crook is uh has married this dude
named albert and they have had a baby
and she's super happy and he has a lot
of money
and [ __ ] like that um but then at some
point some of the prostitutes she's like
hey can you guy like prostitutes babysit
my baby for a minute because i gotta go
do some [ __ ]
uh you know like you do and um and so
before that happens though these
carriages show up
and ann crook and albert both get
kidnapped essentially they get like you
know separated and they get taken away
later on you see ann crook in this room
and she's being interrogated
like who else knows who else knows and
she's just like flipping out
and then they give her a lobotomy and
put her in a mental institution now you
don't really know what the [ __ ] is going
on with this until later on
um unless like i said you've read the
book or you've read about the conspiracy
theory so there's that whole thing
now um at this point there is uh
one prostitute who gets killed now this
is interesting too because the first
woman that gets killed in this
is not one of the canonical five jack
the ripper murders however
this woman was actually killed before
the famous jack the ripper murder
started and some people have speculated
that she was an early victim
of jack the ripper she didn't have the
exact same mutilations but she did have
uh her throat cut and i believe she was
stabbed like a whole bunch of times so
some people have thought that maybe like
it was get it was ramping up as it goes
but that's not usually put in the
canonical five as they call it but um i
can't remember her name was martha
something like started with a t
but yeah so she was the first one to get
killed so at this point um
inspector frederick aberleen abraline i
don't know
uh played by johnny depp he comes on the
scene now here's one thing where this
deviates from the novel
in this um
because i feel like alan moore didn't
like it that he played abraline as
what he called an absent swilling dandy
whereas
in the book he's more like kind of a
gruff like and you know like a
like a regular like inspector type dude
um so he kind of didn't like that change
also um johnny depp in this is
essentially psychic which
now i'm not going to go too far because
in the novel there was a psychic in
there
i don't remember if he was really
psychic though because i think on the
real jack the ripper case they did have
a couple psychics come in but they were
obviously
full of [ __ ] but in this movie uh
johnny depp is an opium addict and when
he goes and smokes opium
he has visions about what's gonna happen
you know what i mean
so he kind of so that's how he gets
insights about the case that's why i
think that that they were going for more
sherlock holmes kind of vibe with that
because that is that is not from the
book so that was something that was
added
so um so he has these visions which
kind of cause him to figure out even
from very very
early on when the prostitutes start
getting picked off one by one
that this is someone he he pretty much
twigs immediately that this
is an educated man someone who is
educated as a surgeon somebody who's
um you know maybe somebody because i
think one of the first victims
was he figures out that well she wasn't
killed here because there's not
any arterial spray or there's anything
like that on the wall even though they
found her like right in the middle of
the [ __ ] sidewalk
so he's like well she must have been
brought here in a carriage which implies
someone with some money
and then he starts finding like all
those little grape
stems like underneath them and at this
time period grapes were super super
expensive
and a prostitute wouldn't have been able
to afford them and then he started
smelling laudanum on their breath so he
just assumed well they lured them in
with into the carriage with some grapes
and then
gave them a drink laced with laudanum
which made him all loopy and then like
he went about all the [ __ ] that he did
yeah and the cops are convinced that it
couldn't be a british man that was doing
this
in english many englishmen yeah yeah the
commissioner he has
foreigners or who has some fantastic
[ __ ] facial hair i have to say it's
just like
sure it's so good um now the thing about
this though is that the commissioner in
this
that was also a real dude but
i don't know i feel like maybe you know
since this is a real person they do kind
of portray him as like oh an english
person who could have done this must
have been some jew or something and it
wasn't anybody that was educated must
been some butcher or something like that
so go
or go look for some quote unquote red
indians or whatever
although you know i think that i seem to
recall
that maybe there was something like that
kind of historically at first
that the cops didn't think that it was
done by it by an englishman
i think there was kind of like some [ __ ]
swirling around and that
quickly vanished yeah that because they
said
in order to walk around freely in that
area with and not
stick out you'd have to be english
because they all were
yeah it had to been somebody that that
that people would have trusted or knew
now it was as far as i know it was
actually historically accurate where
they were saying about how
when the murders first started happening
uh the jews in the area were
targeted by mobs and like people were
like am i supposed to do blah blah blah
so the cops stopped that yeah i don't
know if they did either
um it there might have been a little bit
of that but i'm you know i'm not really
sure because the thing about the jack
the ripper case it's so [ __ ]
complicated i think
we did a show about it a while back but
we only talked about a couple of the
different um
the couple of the different uh suspects
and there were like hundreds
so it's like a whole [ __ ] thing so i
just feel like they didn't
because they didn't have the
investigative techniques back then
because they didn't
um you know really know what they were
looking for they hadn't really seen
anything to this extent before i mean
obviously white chapel in 1888 was very
violent people got [ __ ] beat up and
murdered all the time
but something that was this meticulous
and this um savage
i don't really think that they had seen
anything like that before and they
didn't really have any concept of
why someone would do that they didn't
know what a serial killer was back then
either
yeah that none of that was codified yet
right and almost always
to be a successful serial killer in a
situation like this of course
you have to fit in so they're almost
always known
or or they're kind of just they blend
right in with that scene so whoever it
was it was somebody who was
in white chapel a lot and didn't attract
any attention
i kind of suspect that much as well i've
you know the more i read about it i'm
kind of thinking that
uh chapman dude was maybe i don't know i
lean a little bit more toward that
because he did actually kill people
later when he came back to i think he
went back to the u.s and then he
killed a bunch of his wives now he
poisoned them but
that doesn't necessarily mean that he
wasn't doing the [ __ ] over there
lately i've seen a lot of [ __ ] people
saying like h.h holmes
was no well i mean he was there at the
time like he was in the uk at the time
but i don't know it just seems
h homes was more a profit motivated
killer
i mean he did kind of get off on the
[ __ ] but
he he used people's bodies to sell them
he was very much kind of like gaston
larose uh
a phantom of the opera yeah doing the
same kind of stuff
yeah secret bases and building you know
torture chambers and
you know his his his uh what is it his
murder castle
yeah and stealing money and he was a
serial killer he was
big he was into it but another thing is
is that
those women of white chapel would have
been beneath his tastes
he liked pretty yeah professional type
women and really if you look at serial
killer cases across the ages
they have a certain type and they stick
with it yeah
and uh it was a different man this one i
kind of feel like
um i i feel like even at the time this
was going on and they kind of go into
this a little bit in the movie too
is that i kind of feel like whoever did
this was
punishing the women either because
he didn't like prostitutes or he just
didn't like women in general because
you know one had [ __ ] him over or
something like that i just kind of feel
like it was that
something like that motivation because
why otherwise why
the savagery why this kind of
ritualistic and the thing about this
movie
is that because the murders are so
iconic and because they were so
horrific i mean he would like take
people's organs obviously like
the last murder uh you know which i
think was mary kelly right like that was
the only one that didn't happen in the
street that happened in her
room that she was staying in they
actually as gory as it is in the movie
they toned it down
because he actually did he put the heart
on the [ __ ] fire he took her
intestines out and like strung him
around the [ __ ] room like
bunting man he's like they didn't even
have the crime scene there is yeah it's
black and white thankfully
yeah he removed her face it was just
like a skull or something
he might have done something like well
some of them i think most of the women
were
pretty their faces were pretty well
mutilated um especially like as it went
off because
it just got worse and worse like as it
went on he had time to do it
yeah that room he was somebody who
blended in who fit in they
get kind of knew him i had a feeling
that the girls that he killed had seen
him before
i don't think he killed you every time
he dealt with you yeah
later again yeah he would come back
later again and he could come back later
and get you
so i think they kind of trusted him
because maybe they had done business
with him before
yeah that's what i think but um yeah so
in the movie
they kind of explain not only the
savagery and ritualistic nature of the
murders
but also why these particular women were
targeted
so the conspiracy goes now i will say i
think they went a little bit
it's a little too early like when
because i think at this point in the
movie like only two or three murders
have taken place
and then johnny depp i know his
inspector avalyn but i'm just going to
call him johnny depp because he's
playing himself he's just johnny depp
yeah he's playing so you know he's
pretty much oh hey these murders like
form
a five-pointed star but i was like but
they didn't have five murders at the
time and i just kind of feel like
it's kind of hard to make a five-pointed
star out of five things
out of five things because they're just
kind of like random dots it looks like a
circle
i see that in a lot of horror movies so
they're like you know especially or
serial killer type movies and thrillers
and stuff
they're always just kind of like look it
makes a pattern i'm like no those are
just a couple of dots you can make all
kind of patterns would that just draw a
line that way draw a line that way it's
just
you know it's unless it's you know like
connect the dots okay but it's like you
know what i mean other than that you got
three dots in a line you know that's a
line
yeah to do the five point star you
probably need 12 points to do that
yeah i would think you would at least
need so it was you know definitive
that that's what the pattern was the
pentagon in the second instead of just
like a random
yeah right that's that's all i'm saying
but yeah so he he figures out
that he's like well i think this is
ritualistic i think this is an educated
person
so and we need to you know see what's
going on so what ends up happening
is that he goes to well he goes to this
one surgeon
who uh coincident well not
coincidentally because it's all like
a conspiracy but he was the one that
gave ann crook the lobotomy and threw
her in the [ __ ]
mental asylum so she's like all wigged
out and they can't get any information
out of her really
so then um he goes to that surgeon who's
like hey can you help me out with the
case and the dude's like all [ __ ]
snotty about it and he's just like man
[ __ ] up
so um so johnny depp ends up going to
sir william gull who again i said
spoiler alert ends up being jack the
ripper although at this point uh johnny
depp doesn't know that yet
he's like hey man i need a surgeon to
help me out with this case because i
think the killer might also be a surgeon
but i'm not making the connection that
it might be you so
sir william gaul like i said was the
physician to
uh queen victoria and her family which
as i said he was in real life
um so basically he's very very helpful
at the beginning he's like oh yes it's
this kind of knife and
uh the killer was probably right-handed
even though at the time i'm pretty sure
they thought he was left-handed but i
could be remembering that wrong so i
don't know please correct me
um so you know like i said he's very
very helpful at the beginning
and he seems to you know kind of go with
johnny depp's theories yeah that's cool
and everything like that
now as it goes on uh
johnny depp figures out
through his uh burgeoning romance with
mary kelly and like i said i think
that's why they made
mary kelly in the movie played by
heather graham and made her look like
all clean and have her teeth and
everything like that because
they wanted to set up a love interest
between johnny depp and heather graham
in the movie even though that wasn't in
the book
and obviously in real life they didn't
know each other because mary kelly was
murdered and that's how
that's how aberline like found out about
her he's like here she is she's
all cut up but so they kind of uh he
starts talking to her and she's like
yeah man we knew this
chick named ann crook and she was
married to this dude named albert and he
was like really wealthy and they got
married and we were all at the wedding
and they had a baby
and it was like awesome and then they
both got kidnapped and we don't know
what the [ __ ] happened to them
so as uh so johnny depp is investigating
and he finds out he takes her to
i think it's the national gallery i've
been there but i can't remember what it
looked like
and he shows her uh you know here's the
portrait of queen victoria looking like
queen victoria and then he's like
here's this other portrait um does that
dude look familiar and she says oh my
god
that's albert guess what it's prince
edward victor
now who was also a real person um so
basically what they figure out is that
because
the prince who by the way also has
syphilis
um and can't be because at first they
thought well oh maybe the prince is
jack the ripper but the doctor was like
no he has syphilis and he has like the
shakes and [ __ ] so he wouldn't be able
to like do the mutilations like the way
that they got done
so he ended up marrying anne crook
a commoner and also a catholic which was
a big no no
and they got married in a catholic
church and they had a baby and that baby
would thereby be in succession to
the throne and of course the royal
family couldn't have that so they call
up sir william gaul their
dandy surgeon who is also a mason and
says to this
to him hey can you kind of like take out
these chicks that were all at this
[ __ ]
wedding which is all the prostitutes
that got killed however sir william gull
got a little too
into it um so he they let him do it
but then like at the end they're like
bruh i shouldn't have done that and
they'll like the masons like all punish
him and stuff
but that's what johnny depp figures out
by studying all the mace all the masonic
lore and stuff it's like oh well
you killed these women like
ritualistically by slitting their throat
and like doing all the [ __ ]
like all the five-pointed star [ __ ] so
it was like an occult kind of
uh you know a ritualistic type of thing
which is why they were done but
they do imply that the queen and [ __ ]
like that was not super happy
about it although she didn't stop it
because she just said we just wanted
them taken out like killed we didn't
want them
like [ __ ] mutilated for you to make a
whole thing about it
and like draw attention to it so
that's what really would have happened
right so he did that's why that's why
the writers are giving themselves a
cover
yeah because what really would have
happened is they would have arrested him
on charges
and then sentenced him to death for a
charge they didn't commit that's the
easiest way
yeah but but in this one they get poetic
justice
because well will they take sir william
gaul yeah after
like i said they let him finish and like
kill all the prostitutes even though
i'll get into a little bit
why they let like mary kelly live even
though she did in real life
but um so they so they let him finish
his five
rituals they're like okay fine you
shouldn't have done that but whatever
somebody goes to like the masonic thing
and they're like
bro we don't like that um you know
you're punished or whatever
and he gives them like this snotty
speech about like [ __ ] i'm like a god
now and i'm like way over your [ __ ]
which is kind of like a nod to the novel
because in the novel like i said he
became
like a transcendent being kind of and he
like went through time and [ __ ] like
at the end so that's kind of like a
little stop to that
and uh so they're like okay well we
don't care how [ __ ] elevated you are
we're going to give you a lobotomy just
like they gave to that woman at the
beginning so it was like pared and then
they throw him in a thing and he's just
like sitting there drooling or whatever
and then it turns out uh as i said if
you haven't seen this it's a spoiler
alert but i'm gonna
yeah anyways well like i said it's 2001.
it was a long time ago come on this was
20 years ago if you haven't seen it
jesus christ
um you know what i mean and like i said
it's based on the book a lot of people
have read the book a lot of people have
read the graphic novel a lot of people
have seen the movie so i'm just like not
worried about it
so basically what ends up happening um
so the last murder who in real life was
mary kelly she was the one that was all
[ __ ] up with the intestines
everywhere and the heart on the fire and
whatnot
she's so [ __ ] up that you know johnny
depp goes in there and he's like oh man
my [ __ ] girlfriend's dead look at
this this is horrifying
but then he like pulls up the hair and
the hair is brown now her hair in the
movie is red so he's like oh it's not
her
but he doesn't tell the cops that
because then he knows that the masons
will be after her ass if they know that
she's still alive because they think
she's dead
so basically he's like oh yeah bummer
and then he gives her a bunch of money
so she can get the [ __ ] out of dodge
she takes the baby that was ann crook
and albert's baby
that just got kind of shunted off to
people but she
went and adopted the baby with all the
money and she took the [ __ ] off and went
back to ireland
and um he wanted to go to her and she
kept asking him to she kept writing
letters just like you know here we are
come see us and you know come live with
us out on the farm like on the cliff and
it'll be awesome we'll be happy ever
after
but johnny depp is basically like well i
can't
go out there because if anybody's
watching me because the masons are still
watching me
they'll know she's still alive and
they'll kill her so i can't
so he basically because he loves her so
much
he lets her go because he does not want
her to get killed and
then he dies at the end and it's implied
that he kills himself because he dies in
the opium den
but then when robbie coltrane uh comes
in there who's like the cop that's been
working with him and i love robbie
coltrane you guys
um so he comes in there and he sees that
johnny depp has the two
shillings or whatever the [ __ ] those uh
the coins are like in his hand
and he had made the mention earlier like
and he had done it to one of the victims
earlier we put him on the eyes like for
the
ferryman or whatever so he had them in
his hand almost like he was like whoever
finds me like put these on my eyeballs
so he overdosed deliberately
so i guess so i guess he was one he lost
his girlfriend and he was bummed about
that and two
he thought it'd be better if he was dead
so there was no way for anyone to trace
her through him
so i guess that's why he did i don't
think that happened in the book and in
real life uh frank aberland lived till
he was like 85 years old
so um so that's like again not accurate
at all
but i mean for like a cool interestingly
this is directed by the hughes brothers
who usually they're from detroit
and they usually did like world detroit
based [ __ ] like they did they made like
dead presidents i think they
made uh menace to society stuff like
that so it's like a little bit out of
their wheelhouse
but i think they did a really good job
like with the atmosphere of this like i
said if you don't concentrate too much
on this like this is nothing like the
jack the ripper case
and i understand if you don't like it
because
it's not it's a very very very loose
adaptation of the novel
but as a movie i think it works pretty
well i mean there's a few things in
there that you're like why the hell is
that in there that doesn't make any
sense
but i think the atmosphere makes up for
it the acting is good even though a
couple of the
accents are a little bit biggy um but
you know just with the two americans but
that always happens we talked about that
before with dracula
how they probably should get brits and i
should say too that johnny depp was
actually not the first
pick to be in this i think they wanted
they were talking about jude law
and it's another british actor i can't
remember who it was at the time but they
couldn't do it for whatever reason so he
was like the third or fourth
choice like the first yeah they
approached um
so definitely probably was a good choice
because it got more box office action
yeah and this made quite a bit of money
and the thing about it is that
even though as i said people that were
really into alan moore and really into
the graphic novel
were pissing and moaning about it
because it was you know
not a very good adaptation which i'll
give it that it's not really
that much the same but just as a movie
i think it's a really good movie it's
like a really entertaining i don't know
it's it's like a really creepy like
atmospheric gothic story because i love
all that kind of like
like victorian era like horror i love
all that [ __ ] i put it up there with
coppola's dracula
it's about like that yeah it kind of
reminds me of that and like sleepy
hollow kind of that type of thing that's
more like a colonial america type of
thing but this is like more of a
victorian angle and type of thing it's
been so long
but yeah they they all kind of came out
in the same few years so it all kind of
like
they all have that sort of feel to them
and um it's that's a tone that i like
really well i'm just and i've said
before i'm not a huge fan of like a lot
of the
horror and stuff that came out of the
90s obviously there are you know quite a
few exceptions to that
um but there was something about like
the tone of a lot of 90s horror movies
that i didn't like
but this is more along the lines of
something that i liked from that era i
liked that they were going in this like
kind of
gothic steampunk kind of direction with
a lot of stuff set in victorian
era and i really really like that so i
think it's like really cool like i
really liked all the reds i really loved
all the green lanterns like they tended
to be pretty good from that era too
they did yeah they did that tone yeah it
is
i think interview the vampire was like
at the beginning of it
yeah that kind of yeah so that's a very
similar i think interview with the
vampire came out and went 94.
so it was like it was uh you know a few
years before this
started to kind of build up on the back
of that yeah and
so so this is one that this one one one
that was like a little later in the game
i guess because this didn't come out
until 2001.
but it still has that feel to it and i
really really like that feel i like a
lot of the character work i just like a
lot of this
i think what it was is that a lot of
people that were kind of from the gothic
[ __ ] scene at that time
started to reach approach the age to
where they were going to work in these
studios yeah
and they were starting to have some pull
with
the style of how things looked there was
a lot and [ __ ] the god scene was
popular you had celebrities going to the
to goth club
yeah really it got mainstream a lot like
in the 90s
so a lot of these movies were kind of
built on the back of
the fact that hollywood people were
hanging out in goth clubs yeah
i think that's what and then people with
god's backgrounds were starting to work
you know johnny depp was one of them
him and [ __ ] tim burton i was gonna
say it was a whole ascension of
tim burton and that whole yeah
mainstreaming of that aesthetic
right which prior to that had been very
underground he had
bunches of new people younger people
coming in on the
coattails of [ __ ] tim burton yeah so
that's it so it kind of changed the
the hollywood scene it changed fashion
too you started to see
it's funny because like a few years
later
in the 2000s or in the late 90s you
start seeing
regular people wearing clothes that back
in 93
92 man those are goth clothes yeah so
beat up for wearing
people are dressing like that now so we
had to up our game we were constantly up
in our game
i remember it's funny because i remember
the first time i saw
like a like a you know a normal looking
girl yeah
wearing black nail polish yeah which
when i was in high school
didn't do that if you were black nail
polish everywhere and that's all you had
to have you had black nail polish
everyone thought you were satanists i
think
you know it's weird to say this but i
think buffy the vampire slayer had a lot
to do with that
that they started seeing you started
seeing
girls that weren't goth started to look
like that yeah like doing like darker
lipstick
and darker like oh i'm doing the smokey
eye and i'm doing black
nail polish yeah i'm being this is my
gaff phase yeah like a lot of them
started doing that which a lot of us
were just kind of rolling our eyes but
you know
kind of like uh sugar snaps [ __ ]
remember
ginger snaps i mean yeah ginger stack
called the sugar snaps
ginger snaps not a cereal you had a lot
of girls that looked like those two
girls out of [ __ ] ginger snaps
running around everywhere and that was 2
000 i think yeah
yeah right so right around this same
time period
yeah but you started to see them around
96 though
95 96 yeah yeah i remember those girls
that looked like you see
out of ginger snaps you saw them running
around everywhere
well you had the craft too from 1996.
that was like a big thing from from
around just started to become kind of
mainstream fashion for a while yeah but
yeah i mean
this is definitely like you said this
this is one of the movies
i don't like it quite as much as sleepy
hollow but this is one of the movies
that
it's kind of has a similar tone and it's
one of johnny depp's better roles
even though it's essentially the same
role as sleepy hollow not quite as
goofy because i feel like he's kind of
more like look i have all these gadgets
and stuff like in sleepy hollow which he
doesn't have in this one it's a
he's a lot more serious and he's like
drugged out all the time
but the imagery in this is really cool i
like all the absinthe imagery and like
all his [ __ ] weird visions and [ __ ]
like that
like i said just don't worry about it
it's totally not historically accurate
it's not that close to the book or the
graphic novel it's the same this sort of
story is kind of similar but it has like
a different focus
so just don't worry about that and just
enjoy the movie because it's a good
movie
to me it was like a sherlock holmes
movie yeah and you could definitely tell
that they were trying to go in a more
sherlock holmes
direction because like i said in the
graphic novel
abraline is not really the main
character and jack the ripper is
like sir william is the main character
it was a gothic sherlock holmes movie
kind of felt a little bit like dracula
yeah to me so if you like that yeah then
you'd probably like this as well
and like i said it seemed like it got it
got decent reviews at the time roger
ebert really dug it like a lot of you
know
people really dug it there's still when
it was cut when it first came out it was
cutting edge yeah
yeah i remember it just don't get mad
because it's not historically accurate
right
that's all i'm saying all right we will
uh see you
on the next one oh this movie is on hulu
by the way if you want to watch it uh if
you don't have i thought we had the
blu-ray but i looked through
all our [ __ ] and i didn't see it so i
was like well it's on hula we'll watch
it on there
so if you want to watch it all right so
uh that'll do it for this movie
respective and we'll see you on the next
one
bye